well news of this story has spread
nationwide but the shock of course
resonating here locally especially at
the public administrator's building
where telus still currently holds an
elected position 8 news now reporter
candace charles with more
the
building where robert ellis work is
still closed and i've spoken to some of
the people who are running for his
position now and they tell me that this
all comes as a shock of course public
administration building was searched by
police wednesday morning employees were
told to go home wednesday afternoon and
it's been closed ever since i reached
out to the city official who beat tell
us in the primaries for the position
read read her husband told me her phone
was confiscated during the search reads
on the november ballot with tablet al
debug and patsy brown for tell us his
position as public administrator brown's
campaign team told me this incident has
everyone including brown on alert the
concern of personal safety
and i know that's something that a lot
of the employees of the public
administrator's office even the
candidates who are also
seeking office for public administrator
that's something that is going to
resonate and be at the forefront of
their mind brown had a bid of
controversy herself she was recently
arrested for a dui her campaign team
says she's been warning her father and
that she was set to meet with german
next week i reached out to tabitha and
didn't get a response but the county
sent this statement saying quote the
death of jeff grammon was both shocking
and tragic and we joined with our
community and being stunned at how this
situation has continued to evolve over
the last few days the public
administrator is an elected position and
the county is reviewing its options
under the law regarding robert telus's
current status as the public
administrator the safety of our county
employees and the public is our top
priority and the county has suspended mr
telus access to county offices or
property they say it is undetermined at
this time when this building will be
open of course we will keep you up to
date with stick with us right here for
the latest